[موسيقى]
حرب من نوع اخر بقياده روسيا
سلاحها التكنولوجيا وابطالها قراصنه
اما هدفها تسجيل نقطه دخول لا تدمير مواقع
تلويح بوتن باستخدام سلاح النووي يبدو انه
ترجم فعليا
تقريرا لرويترز كشف ان عمليات قرصنه روسيه
وقعت بين اغسطس وسبتمبر الفائتين
استهدفت ثلاثه مختبرات نوويه الامريكيه
جنود حرب الكرملين الالكترونيه الذين
يطلقون على انفسهم اسمها كولد ريفر قاموا
بانشاء صفحات تسجيل دخول مزيفه
وارسلوا بريد الكترونيا الى العلماء
لمعرفه كلمات المرور الخاصه بهم
معلومات استخباراتيه الهجمات الالكترونيه
وقعت في حين يتفقد خبراء الامم المتحده
محطه
النوويه
في القرصنه وتستخدم التجسس الالكترونيه
للحصول على ميزه تنافسيه
اخطائنا عديده قامت بها مجموعه كولد ريفر
كشفت عمق علاقاتها مع روسيا
وسماحات لمحللي الامن السيبراني بتحديد
موقع المجموعه وهويه احد اعضائها
اذا ظهرت عناوين البريد الالكتروني
المستخدمه انها تنتمي لروسيا يدعى اندري
كورينتس